the love fest continues for Aubree  Rihanna surprised her beau Drake at his  summer 16 tour stop in LA Saturday  joining him on stage to perform their  sexy do at work the two lovebirds  couldn't keep their eyes or hands off  each other and concert goers went wild  for the pair's  PDA the rapper even took a moment in  between performances to profess his love  for the Barbados beauty again  okay I'll credit my saliva that holds  you down like this one  the hotline bling' hitmaker gushed about  RiRi even more before she left the  building the Staples Center tweeted this  adorable onstage moment please one more  time but it's incredible beautiful  talented  what would time for Rihanna tonight la  please